hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to portal 2 with Patrick
also known as Schad leech say hi hello
hello hi everybody if you don't remember
Patrick he is from the make-a-wish
Foundation er he's not from the
make-a-wish Foundation but last year I
did a video with Patrick telling you
guys about his wish he wanted to be a
youtuber and now he's bad and added
about a year now
ah so tell us how it's going it's going
good made about 100 videos so far I'm
actually getting used to it learning how
to edit and such going better than I
thought it was actually yeah I mean it
took me a long time to learn like all
the editing stuff like I wouldn't say I
was an expert at until like two three
years in but if you guys out there
watching need of reintroduction to
Patrick I'll put a link in the
description below of the video that we
first made together when I went up to
visit him in Oregon but for now we have
portal 2 to play and this isn't the
campaign for co-op
this is community levels blow my
goodness what Elias and I've never
played a community level inside portal
heirloom played co-op in portals yeah
and the thing about community levels is
apparently they're made a lot different
than normal levels are because holy crap
what the hell okay so I'm assuming that
with this we need to go play all
murdered yes I know
haha very funny the basis of all humor
on youtube if you want to be a good
youtuber you got to learn how to handle
your balls so yeah alright so we got two
of them it sees my just coming through
the portal several times yeah my
assumption is that this is supposed to
pick up speed going down but it doesn't
seem to be a very smooth transition so
I'm just gonna hope for the best
and then we're gonna put this may be
awesome it doesn't work this doesn't
seem to work and okay so the energy
astral we ever owned to portal sets you
have your set I have mine yeah yeah
that's the basic of portal 2 everyone
knows the basis of portal 2 in fact
everyone out there is automatically
smarter than we are and have already
figured this level out and we're stupid
for not getting there yet so we got to
pick up our game here so what we need to
do
we need to get at the fundamental level
we need get the ball from there all the
way over to that platform in there this
just means that that's gonna go there
that flow you have to grab the ball no
I'm pretty sure we have to make the ball
pick up momentum and then roll down at
least twice there goes there because
there's one wall here and while there
then there's the white walls up here
yeah but we need to get it enough speed
so that it launches from this platform
all the way up there so the the basic
roll through isn't enough it's just
gonna bounce around and then fall
through so it needs we need to find a
way to get this to pick up momentum or
else we're not gonna get anywhere so how
do we do that Patrick ahi hey come up
with a solution and hope something
happens that's not how anything is done
only action can find our way through
this so we gotta act I just need to find
a better way to get this to speed up
because it keeps hitting a block like
every single time it hits it hits like a
space it doesn't go smoothly from one
point to the other and I can't grab it
so we need momentum how do we get
momentum though I can pick the ball up
well yeah congratulations you picked up
the ball but how do we get the ball from
here to there because the ball can't fit
through there but oh I guess it can well
good job there land it over there you're
really you're really conjuring up a
storm of brain activity alright at least
feel something going on no we have
nothing going on you have less going on
than what I had going on so just bear
with me let the genius move through this
and you just sit there all pretty yep
I'll sit here
you don't forget the bean pretty part
because that's very essential yeah yeah
okay now isn't it glorious it's yeah man
it's kind of nope it just gets stuck
everyone so long it'll like it'll keep
going for a while and then it'll not
yeah man is it literally like if that
precise portal as low as it can go
ah you know I don't know there's there's
so many different ways like that you can
get speed but the thing about this
design here on this level is that this
is an imprecise structure they had like
finagle the level design to even make
this work so I don't know what it wants
or what I could guess is that I can at
least make it go through one time on the
second time through it'll go and roll
and then it Pam okay it's gonna go and
it's gonna roll once through and then
the second time it'll do nothing yeah
that did nothing we've reached no
progress this level sucks and I hate it
little stupid I got the balls stuck in
the wall gosh here shows your anger yeah
whatever
my anger is nothing compared to what I'm
gonna do when I break down the walls of
this level so okay it's okay so all
right let me get here well this the ass
since I've never done ooh whoa ooh ooh
forget forget the idea forget the idea
okay
watch this get this ball out of here get
that ball out of here
get this ball out of here you take this
ball from me take it there we go okay
watch this I I can pick up speed okay so
I need you to place these portals that
I'm going through because I can't place
the outside portal and what you're gonna
do is you're gonna place the portal on
the inside of the loop-d-loop
and then I can jump through you can pass
me the ball and then I can get in the
place okay ready I'm at maximum velocity
go for it ah see tada see see you shove
that through before by letting it go
through and I I almost had it you
grabbed it back there we go done and
done
see genius we're all super smart and we
opened the door don't you feel
accomplished this is what it means when
people are smart and do good
I can easily tell that is the smartest
thing we've done this year
yay probably at least okay now you tell
me what you see in there because I can't
go in oh that doesn't help me at all
but it's a camera good job I don't even
know what to do okay I see a hole then
there's another button there's another
button close to the door that you
entered that area right over here so if
you can come back and press that button
then I can open the door behind me and
there's another button in there that
probably is gonna be fun
no no no that's fine okay see now you
can come oh that wait press that button
both of us press this button okay that
didn't do anything
go through the door okay and then just
walk around the corner and you'll see me
on the other side see okay so now it's
just a it's a physics tilt puzzle we
have to get this ball together to all of
the orange dots I believe that's
probably what it wants so you want to
tilt it this way yeah you've got you
tilton I'll tilt it after it gets to the
point where I need to tilt it but for
right now you need you you are in the
main control this is like you've got the
hard job here so it's gonna roll that's
gonna go through there it's gonna touch
the orange nope okay so we need to avoid
the orange I got it okay so avoiding the
orange so I got tilt
okay got this Wow this is actually
really cool okay now whoops I need ya
okay wait you let go and then I'll let
go real quick here okay no no you you
let go stay let go and then okay and
then it'll tilt and then you stay like
oh stay let go stay stay let go stay let
go there okay now go back on oh no no no
no no no on damn it it's gonna be good
okay dang it I I screwed that up
okay okay no I I got it I got it
no no you you had it you had it good you
just got to get back on okay here we go
oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah that's
the one
okay okay okay so all right so we got to
go all the way to the white which means
okay just let it go down and then we'll
just squeeze right in there well at this
point we're going to Merc you're perfect
perfect perfect
yes okay oh look at this here have the
ball
boink see we did it now I should be able
to go through or at least you can help
me get through if you wait how do I get
out help
that doesn't help stop looking at the
camera help me get through the door you
know the buttons before the important
buttons oh yeah your buttons oh yeah do
buttons okay so now it's just open okay
so yeah tah-dah
we got through it okay so we're both
here are we doing
okay good job
oh god what is this what is this okay
firstly ah first step is create a bridge
second step is fall on the target third
step is ball in a pit I don't know what
that means if it's drop so there's a lot
above each and just adds in our dot yeah
okay and what does this do whoa hello is
this a nerville so that's that's another
velocity when you're exactly correct so
you put your portals there good okay now
I'm going to I need to get up there
before I can no actually I don't cuz you
can press in on the platform yeah what
let me let me just I can just get there
we go whoop whoop oh there we go okay so
now I can gather velocity but you have
to launch me with the red on one of the
portals like or one of the platforms
right there or right there so I don't
know which one but good luck
I'm putting my life in your hands that's
probably not a good idea
I know but go for it it's the only
choice I have okay so I'm up here that's
interesting but now we're stucked here
enough stuff freeze up there yeah
there's nothing up here put a door I
can't get through because there's a blue
dotted line that follows all the way to
the other side oh I was supposed to go
up that side you went the wrong side how
could you how could you I'm sorry you're
the one that pointed ibj whatever you
hang on
you gotta undo that cuz I'm not there
yet step off the thing okay now okay Hey
gosh dang it
huh just step on the button when I'm
midair know when I'm midair hep hep hep
what I midair not what I'm the sun's air
goddammit come on work with me here ah
you're so wrong Wyatt no you're not try
harder God come on and don't say I can't
fit up here cuz I'm short cuz I'm not
yeah there we go that's the stuff that's
a winner right there
I believed in you the whole time of
course ow
wrong tour halt ow can you uh no no no
country how about you yeah there we go
okay let's try this again with less out
of my face
that doesn't help doesn't help doesn't
help doesn't help spill fun alright go
oh yes ow again wrong portal why would
you do that I'm gonna assume you're
doing this on purpose three
- one way okay so I need a ball up here
apparently so I needed to see y'all ball
down here oh so I needed to be carrying
a ball with me so give me that give me
that give me that give me that give me
give me there we go give let go
thank you all right now let's do this
very challenging why is it it's like it
it's like there's a okay there we go
okay so HUP HUP HUP
there we go first try getting good okay
I'm almost full velocity not yet hold
hold
okay I'm full velocity we all right and
then flew doink okay good there and then
we just both need to go up that way so
to do that but did you see anything up
there that last bit portal no no we
don't need to go of that side we already
got let's see how the blue line is now
orange that means the circuit is
completed in the door is open I have you
back up on the earth side we both have
to get back up here
ooh yes so the interesting part about
that is ooh there's stuff up there hang
on one second hope okay ah this is this
would make things not easier this
doesn't make anything easier huh cuz
there's no one to stand on that limb on
the air side there's also one yeah so
what are these two I think these are
just ledges that we could jump through
thank you I was gonna fly through that
could you know do greedy stop being
greedy let me let me let me explore my
genius and then you can do your thing
fine all right now I'm going to put this
here i watch this hope fluttering and ah
just barely not enough
Oh No Oh No is there someone where I
have to make that velocity again bend
you're somehow able to do that I mean
that should be able to do it it seems
like that's enough let me just try one
more time maybe I wasn't fast enough on
it all right maybe I wasn't precise
enough so let me tread skip
hop whoop okay not quite okay this is a
conundrum that we're gonna have to
figure out next time we make this video
so for now well pause it but we'll get
back to this in just a second so thank
you everybody so much for watching if
you want check out Patrick's channel
it's Schad leach there's a link in the
description below and check out the
video that we made in Oregon together so
thank you again and as always we will
see you in the next video bye
- put two things mouth is that - that
tooth was stuffing things oh I gave him
the bone